[Music]
did my second did my second toe
yesterday oh [__] yeah
[Music]
yeah it's his [__] backpack dude yeah
[__] me up this morning damn it I feel
like such a nerd sorry tell me about the
toe and then I'll tell you about the
back my toe
yeah my silver is yours yeah no I just I
did my second
second toe I'm like I basically have a
CDL now nice yeah you gonna get a CDL
one day
probably not
do you actually have to get that no oh
okay I'm just trying to set you over the
seat
CDL
oh CD CDs alone what what would it be
you just sorry you just you see the L
that's it you threw me off when you said
second toe I just started getting a
little horned up
so there's two of them
yeah
damn two toes huh yeah nah I do my
second toe
uh big in Middle
those are my favorite yeah no I I pulled
it off so much quicker
I felt like the first one
you know we had a lot of help a lot of
eyes on it this one I could do it Solo
felt good easy peasy yeah it was easy
peasy but now you know I've been I've
been shopping race trailers
so what trailer did you use uh the
creator of the hotline or the engineer
of the hot lapse desk it was his it was
his okay yeah how much are trailers
I mean it's a range you know open
trailer not too expensive even a
enclosed trailer isn't too expensive but
when you get one like if you're getting
enclosed they're bare bones so it's just
like a wooden interior so six hundred
thousand dollars dude
Ah that's that's just like the starting
price it's not that much
you know we got a portfolio as big as
mine
not but to get them when you get them
like nice and include like a nice
enclosed trailer with like with AC and
yeah sealed interior do they actually
have AC yeah dude what yeah bro bro look
at these double stackers
for what reason uh because sometimes the
team will you know they'll have like
computers and other [__] in there and
sense yeah and it's just luxury I just
can't believe trailers actually get to
this much that's why racing is so
expensive dude if you got this you're
probably Towing you know a full-size
race car that's actually like very nice
yeah and it probably takes a lot of or
you're just some [__] Rich dude that
can afford it and you're like yeah [__]
it
Towing my Porsche in this no just just
tell her just just Towing it yeah just
because yeah
look up 55-foot trailer sorry this is
all I do now I just look at race trailer
trailers yeah well that one is crazy
that was sick that one's probably got a
bet in it
this is like me pulling up golf clubs
yeah on the screen and be like these are
the ones I've been looking at yeah this
is my dream clubs my dream
is to just have one of these that I can
just pull around whenever I want [__]
did any of these have like an RV also oh
yeah yeah oh yeah are you kidding man so
you can tow your car yeah behind your
car and then also live in your car yeah
I mean what more could you ask for
that's
the American dream what more could you
ask freely you know
next time we're going on so or is that
what I'm doing yeah is the point of that
like you you you're traveling to
different tracks yeah I mean if you're
like a race team or if you're maybe
going to do an endurance race typically
racing you're there for like at least
three days so you're gonna you're gonna
do your practice day quality day and
then you stay there yeah a race day
and you just never leave so you're never
more than six feet away from your car
yeah
you know get up and get after it you
know yeah that's sick
yeah so you know
yeah I've been getting been getting
horned up looking at these this is porn
for me now I want to look at people
[__] and sucking each other I just I
just go to the ATC you know custom
listings
I'm like oh
electronic lift oh
um so my toe yeah yeah tell us about
your toe Okay so
this backpack I haven't used it since I
was traveling can we get a visual that's
10 years old I use this in Southeast
Asia so I'm like half expecting like you
know myself to like open up one of the
pockets and like for a whip it to fall
out or something like that
and still works yeah exactly yeah well I
mean I would test it yeah oh damn yeah
I didn't think that [__] would work
oh [__]
um
so I have this backpack I loaded it I
actually I put a bunch of [__] in it
like I got a bunch of like camping
supplies and then I put a 20 pound
dumbbell in it
so then I do this hike like every every
day now or something like that what is
this Wiki fee yeah you're on Wiki why I
don't know you were gonna tell us about
your toe so I brought it up
this is the rating 5.3 out of five so
that's like better than perfect
I mean I'm
I'm flattered thank you well
they like them toes thank you so much
damn damn this is this is weird
yeah stop being funny didn't it yeah it
did
yep
that's every single picture of my feet
yeah like
like
I wonder if anyone has jacked off to
these you wonder
you wonder you definitely know that for
a fact I know that for um
trust me I know a hundred percent that
someone I'm getting rid of you
I'm getting rid of you bad little come I
don't know what you're a violent little
coming there I'm getting ready yeah
you're trying to you're trying to poison
me oh we're just doing back
yeah yeah
you're totally [__] that's a little
different it's a little different you're
so yeah that's that's more back Europe
get out come get out get out of my balls
[Laughter]
get out of my balls you [__] you're gonna
tell the other come to come out when you
see some feet I gotta get rid of you my
balls are full of [__] I gotta get rid of
the come
will come tainting
it's changing my nuts degenerate little
[__] yeah my nuts are my nuts would be
good but they're filled with calm
I think I'll be healthier if I had less
[__] in my balls
so anyways so anyway we're talking about
you're towing this giant backpack with a
20 pound dumbbell in it yeah yeah this I
mean there's nothing really much else to
say
I did a hike I do this hike like all the
time and it's pretty easy for me now
yeah
but today with that extra 25 pounds for
30. yeah it was tough yeah
it's weird it's like weird you're like
body adjusts to like the change in
center of gravity and then when you take
it off it just felt like I was oh yeah
you're like slanted yeah I got vertigo
it was bizarre but this shit's gonna be
hard
yeah
head to the steering wheel yeah that guy
drives like a [__]